the FBI is trying to track down the
source of suspicious packages sent to
military installations and other
locations around Washington DC at least
one is tested positive for explosives
and this morning we've learned that the
National Security Agency and Secret
Service were targeted in addition to the
bases that you see here on the screen
David Martin is at the Pentagon with the
latest on this story David good morning
good morning the first package was
received yesterday at approximately 8:30
a.m. at the National Defense University
at Fort McNair in Washington it was
flagged as suspicious during the normal
screening process and the building was
evacuated the package contained
materials that tested positive for
explosives including black powder it
also appeared to have a fuse attached
packages were also reported at a number
of other bases one was addressed to the
National Security Agency and another was
stopped at the Secret Service mail
facility all of the packages were
rendered inert my disposal units at each
base and sent to the FBI lab at Quantico
Virginia for examination some of the
packages also include a letter which one
law enforcement source described as
threatening and rambling Anthony David
Martin at the Pentagon this morning
thanks David